finally we know what the secret project
is as JMS announces The Babylon 5
animated movie Welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
I've known about this for three months
thanks to my sources over at Warner
Brothers but I was sworn to secrecy but
I am very excited now that it has been
finally announced by J Michael zaczynski
on his Twitter page that we are getting
a Babylon 5 animated movie made by
Warner Brothers animation this gives us
even more confidence that we're going to
be getting the Babylon 5 reimagined live
action series later in the year I'm told
that once the writer's strike is sorted
it's going to get virtually an immediate
green light where it's going to end up
CW Max is it called Max again H2O Max I
forgot what's called this week
um or even maybe Apple
wherever ends up I am very excited about
the live action series the reimagined
version of Babylon 5. but how about this
animated movie
what do we know
well
he's keeping his cards close to his
chest but he is saying that this time
next week he will be announcing the
title of the movie when it's going to be
released and maybe a few more details
about the project itself I was only
really told that it was happening I
wasn't really told any details except to
say that apparently it is connected to
the Original Series so everything that
happened the original series still
happened I did wonder if it was going to
be a prequel to the reimagined new
Babylon 5 that's coming but apparently
it isn't
um but to be fair my source isn't 100 on
that but what does suggest it is but
apparently pretty much all of the
surviving cast and Bruce brooksland
there Etc do voice their original
characters so to me that screams that it
is actually a Babylon 5 that we know of
movie
I actually am really really excited
about this I think it's going to be very
very cool Warner Brothers animation
actually has an amazing history of
making some really excellent projects I
mean just look at everything they've
done with the DC in the last 20 years
really the DC live action stuff has been
a bit but the DC animated stuff has
genuinely been quite brilliant even the
Batman Samurai which is a ridiculous
ridiculous storyline
was brilliant so we can be confident I
believe that they're going to release
something very very exciting
so guys
get into the comments tell me what you
think is this a project that you're
looking forward to an animated movie of
Babylon 5 by Warner Brothers animation
JMS has been working on this for quite a
while we can confirm that it is done
it's in the can it's ready to be
released so we might get this on our
screen sooner rather than later it's
really going to be interesting to see
where this actually is if it's on the CW
does that mean the reimagined Babylon 5
is going to be following it or if it's
on Max does it mean it's more likely
that the reimagine show is going to go
there or God forbid
what if it's on Apple I think it really
where this cartoon ends up will be a big
hint to tell us where the reimagined
live action series will follow
get in the comments guys and tell me
exactly what you're thinking about these
are a very exciting announcement is this
something that will be connected to the
original universe so therefore something
we really really want to see even if
you're not that excited about a
reimagined Babylon 5 reboot or will this
be a kids cartoon and therefore
something you're not interested in I'm
really hoping it's going to be a little
grittier and a little bit more for the
grown-up fans I imagine it will be get
in the comments don't tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos when we try to get you the
news on everything sci-fi as quickly as
humanly possible also you go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
helps the channel you get to see it
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
thank you